now today is an anniversary today is the
20th anniversary of the appreciat can
you believe it oh and and two days ago
was the ten-year anniversary of the
premiere of kuru town I have like a big
week in television history I guess
I wrote both of those down because those
are both iconic moments in my life yeah
yeah it's really special and it's also
so nice I guess because of streaming
platforms and accessibility to shows
people keep finding both of those shows
and loving them and what re watching
them watching them for the first time I
have fans that are now like my
daughter's age who are watching freaks
and geeks for the first time and it's
really special I got like I got like I'm
gonna try not to I get very emotional
about it
I want cooter town to come back more
than anything in the entire I think we
should do a movie I'm gonna put that in
the universe I think we should do like a
Netflix movie Netflix are you listening
see Phillips wants a cougar town movie
yeah we'll do it for cheap tonight we
are celebrating Elizabeth Banks she's
the first female director to receive
this honor and only the fifth woman to
ever get the honor yeah in the history
since 1947 yeah Wow okay
we had a a pentamer little yeah there
are more men named Robert the diversity
of the award then women Wow facts sad
facts well anyway I'm so I'm so thrilled
that Liz is receiving this honor as a
director but I'm a friend and a fan I've
known her for a really long time and one
of the best qualities about Liz is not
just her work ethic and who drive in
this industry but also how much she
cares about helping others all of the
organizations that she's involved in and
how much she shows up for others
including myself she's
consistently showed up for me over the
years and so when I was asked to post
tonight
I of course that yes I was
cross-referencing er IMDb's because I
was like there's no way these two
haven't started something we haven't
worked together no we've never been
there work together I know we had I did
I had a dinner with Liz and Gillian
Jacobs a couple years ago and we were
like however the three of us not playing
sisters in something when is that movie
happening but yeah I just I've known her
personally forever for so long and yeah
our kids are in the same class like
words were buddies speaking of
supporting friends I I don't know if
you've seen but you have basically
become like the gift of the Emmys with
you supporting Michelle Williams and
yeah one of them one of them I prefer
Jason Bateman's but you know I you
listen any
any moment you can be giftable that's a
win I don't know I just I obviously love
my friends so much so dearly it's the
only thing that really matters in this
world and the other night I was overcome
with how proud I am of her and how
incredible she is to have used her
moment where people were celebrating her
to shine a light on the truth of the
situation which is both you know pay
equality is still a thing that we're
fighting for in 2019 and
and I I just was beyond proud that
speech alone deserves its own Emmy next
year totally I agree with you
beautifully delivered a my best
supporting in that speech
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]